Hát hành thoán thông tin mặt đang trở thành lợi sọt của những người tư dùng, công bối dụi này,
căn gân hàng cũng liên tục mở giọt hệ sinh thái ư đái sản trở chủ thể.
Tương ngày 15.8 đến hết ngày 30.8, mọi nằm hành hình thông trạm 20 xấu,
A Kui Bán chỉnh 2 chuẩy ư đái, A Kui Cato, Thay Lời Môn nói, gọi trọt chiến anh,
zánh cho phát hằng sự dụng thể quốc tế A Kui Bán GCB.
Theo đó, phát hành thệ tính dụng quốc tế A Kui Bán GCB, Anh Chi Minh,
bao gồm thệ chính và thệ phụ, đông thời có tổng dành số thành tỏan hàng hãng,
giữ vụ hợp lệ từ ba trợ đồng trở lên sẽ được khoan tiền lên đến một trụ đồng,
theo chương trình, Theo ba, Hành Môn.
Bên cảnh đó, chủ thể tính dụng quốc tế A Kui Bán GCB,
có được hưởng nhiều u đã khi mùa sám trên sop y,
bao gồm giả trực tiếp từ 5.8 đến 2 trong mình đồng,
cho 1 đơn hàng vào cả ngày thường và các ngày đặc biệt,
như 3 tháng 3, chỉ tháng chính, mùa tháng 1, 1 tháng 1, 1 tháng 1,
chủ thể cũng được giảm sống như đồng khi sự dụng sop y phút.
Tại hệ thống Aion trên toàn quốc,
phát hàng nhận vụ khoa tạng buồn sám chỉ giả 2 trong như đồng,
khi thành tỏan trực tiếp từ một trụ đồng trở lên.
Sống sông vừa đó, phát hàng có được khoan mươi phân chăm tổng giả trị thành tỏan trong tháng,
tối ra 5 trong như đồng, đối với các sâu dịch thành tỏan hàng hãng,
sịch vụ hợp lệ tại các đơn vị trước nhận thành tỏan ở nước ngoài,
khi thăm ra chính trình, A Kui Bán GCB, Chí Thio toàn Cầu,
trả nghiệp bản sắc A Đầu.
Đại diện A Kui Bán Chò biết,
chứng trên được trình 2 với mỗi mỗi xa khang giả trị cho tương sâu dịch,
đồng thời mở giộng hệ xin thái yêu đại,
thông qua hợp tác với nhiều đối tác trong vảng ngoài nước.
Trong bối cảnh thành tỏan không dục tiên mặt nha càng phục biến,
ngân hàng kì vọng mạnh đến cho khách hàng,
têm nhiều trả nghiệp thành tỏan hiện đại,
ăn toàn và tự lợi,
đồng thời nâng cao giả trị sự dụng của các sống thể quốc tế A Kui Bán GCB.